Stephen Colbert kicks off the 69th  Annual Primetime Emmy Awards for the  politically charged monologue and an  unexpected special guest  [Applause]  a 53 year old late night host took some  expected jabs at president Donald Trump  during Sunday's opening of the Emmys and  poked fun at our political climate but  the most surprising moment period both  in person and around the world  Colbert brought out former press  secretary Sean Spicer and by the looks  of the audience they were in complete  shock the Melissa McCarthy who's won an  Emmy for her portrayal of the 45 year  old political aide on SNL seemed  unimpressed with the cameo so I put him  out that's right spicies back Sara's out  [Applause]  [Music]  you